Und schon wieder kündigt sich eine verblüffende erkenntnis an ein forschungsteam hat im zentrum unserer galaxis etwas verblüffendes gefunden einen ganzen haufen
schwarzer löcher noch ist es nicht ganz sicher doch der verdacht erhärtet sich mehr mehr was dafür und was dagegen spricht und welche
Konsequenzen diese erkenntnis hat jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Und übrigens wieder mal einen themenvorschlag der über whatsapp
Reinkamen vielen dank an die hammer community dort wie er da rein kommt erfahrt ihr am ende
des videos diese entdeckung ist mal wieder ehrlich
Unglaublich und verändert wahrscheinlich mal wieder die sicht auf unser universum ist sieht so aus als ob um das schwarze loch
im zentrum unserer galaxie der milchstraße
Hunderte kleinere schwarze löcher kreisen schon länger gab es diesen verdacht. Um das zentrum der milchstraße
Kreisen ja unzählige objekte aber bisher war es eben nur ein verdacht dass es dort auch schwarze löcher gebe jetzt konnte ein team um den
astrophysiker charles jay haley erstmals konkrete hinweise dafür finden dass wohl hunderte schwarze löcher um das große
supermassereiche schwarze loch sagittarius a stern in zentrum der milchstraße kreisen sind nicht viel schwerer als die sonne
Aber es gibt eine menge davon es sind stellare schwarze löcher
also
Solche die aus der masse eines zusammengestürzten sterns entstehen und dann kaum weitere
materials ihn aufgespürt hat das forschungsteam die schwarzen löcher in den daten des weltraumteleskops
chandra dort fanden sie zunächst hunderte punkte von denen
energiereiche strahlung ausgeht das sind röntgen binärsystem
kombinationen aus schwarzen löchern und einem stern oder einem neutronenstern und einem normalen stand das wird vermutet alle fünf bis zehn jahre
sparen sie eine große menge
Röntgenstrahlung aus wenn kein schwarzes loch dabei ist allerdings gab es sechs runden quellen ohne
größere ausbrüche
Das forschungsteam vermutet dass es sich eben um schwarze löcher handelt sollte diese erkenntnis bestätigt werden dann dürften sich
hunderte solche systeme mit kleinen schwarzen löchern rund um santa rosa stern befinden das team vermutet sogar
300 bis 500 solcher schwarzen löcher
im abstand von nur 3,3 lichtjahren rundum sagittarius
Aussterben bei mir kommt ja sofort wieder die theorie der schwarzen löcher statt der dunkle materie hoch wenn es immer wieder
Mehr schwarzer löcher entdeckt werden man kann es sogar sein dass irgendwann gar kein platz mehr für dunkle materie ist und ist da schon
Dadurch bestätigt wird das wäre sensationell aber noch gibt es nicht annähernd
Schwarze löcher die das erklären würden aber sie sind zumindest genauso schwer zu finden wie die dunkle materie, am ende
habe ich euch ein video noch
Zu dieser these verlinkt naja es bleibt spannend wenn er als erstes neues zum thema schwarze löcher und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt wie
eben auch die dunkle materie
dann
Endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen andern
vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen oder mit themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen
Und mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau blogger vergessen wie geht es weiter dafür auch. Draufklicken eben mit dem video dunkle materie
rätsel gelöst spielen schwarze löcher eine rolle ansonsten bis dann
bleibt